[Music]
California leads softened talk left when
it comes to family from Facebook
celebrating family diversity to hide
movies like marriage story ending in
divorce but my new research with Wendy
Wong indicates that these leads
generally live right when it comes to
their own family life we found that many
neighborhoods at the apex of cultural
and economic power in the Golden State
from San Francisco's Pacific Heights to
Beverly Hills have remarkably low rates
of single parenthood even in Hollywood
in the Whitley Heights neighborhood just
down the hill from the Hollywood sign we
find virtually no single parents these
California eats know the stable marriage
gives their own kids a better shot at
flourishing in school avoiding trouble
with the law and achieving the American
dream for the sake of kids across
America these elites
including those in Hollywood should
publicly promote what they privately
affirm raising kids and stable
two-parent families can go a long way in
setting them up for success do you think
Hollywood should present a more positive
view of American family life let us know
in our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI